[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
should i test the mic or i mean the mic
should i
it's working fine okay okay
is
welcome to the nih i'm colleen mcgowan
director of the nih office of research
services
overseeing many of the campus operations
that support the health and safety of
the national institutes of health staff
including the vaccination program we are
here at the nih clinical center
the nation's research hospital often
referred to
as the house of hope where more than 500
000
clinical research participants have been
active partners
in medical discoveries since the
hospital opened in 1953.
patients come from around the world to
the nih
as partners in research and we currently
have 1600 clinical research studies
underway
at the clinical center discoveries
emerging from
nih funded research results in better
ways to prevent
diagnose and treat disease to help
people live
longer healthier lives and reduce the
burden of disease and disability
it is fitting that we gather here today
on the nih campus
to administer vaccines designed to
battle covid19
at the very place where much of the
groundbreaking vaccine development
work happened both at the nih vaccine
research center around the corner
and here in the nih clinical center
additionally the clinical center has
several clinical trials
to better understand covid19 and how
best to treat it
this vaccine will help protect future
patients
and healthcare staff who care for them
today we are kicking off the
nih covid19 vaccine program beginning
with
opening remarks and followed by
vaccinations
importantly additional clinical center
healthcare staff
will be inoculated over the next days
and weeks
as we receive additional doses of the
vaccine from state health departments
today's distinguished guests include hhs
secretary alex azar ii
nih director dr francis collins
america's doctor dr tony fauci
who is also the director of the national
institute of allergy and infectious
diseases
the nih institute leading the covit 19
response
we also have six of our front-line
healthcare workers
who we consider our greatest heroes we
are honored to have them here today
and know that they represent the
hundreds of thousands of
healthcare workers across the nation who
are selflessly caring for covenanting
patients
often at great personal risk
nih thanks all health care workers for
their commitment
and dedication during this difficult
time
now i invite the nih director dr francis
collins to the stage
for his opening remarks
well good morning to all of you on this
historic day
the events of the last two weeks were
not just one but
two covet 19 vaccines have been
authorized for emergency use
just 11 months after this virus first
appeared on our radar
have been truly astounding many prayers
have been lifted up over this terribly
difficult year that an answer
to this global pandemic might emerge
from the dedicated work of our
scientists
i will admit that quite a few of those
prayers were mine
and now it is with great pride and joy
and gratitude
that i stand here today awaiting the
historic moment
when the first frontline healthcare
workers at nih
along with a few of our nation's public
health leaders
will receive their first dose of a covet
19 vaccine
i'm proud to say that the messenger rna
technology used for both
of the covid vaccines now authorized by
fda
rest on fundamental research conducted
right here at nih
at our vaccine research center 100 yards
over there and right here at our own
clinical center
in particular the moderna vaccine being
administered here today
arose from a close collaboration of the
company with nih
established even before the covet 19
pandemic began
not only has nih contributed
fundamentally to the research
underlying the mrna vaccines we're
equally proud to have played a crucial
role in supporting
other covid related research across the
u.s
that includes forming an unprecedented
partnership with industry called
active to accelerate progress in
therapeutics as well as vaccines
and it includes a program called red x
that put nih in the role of venture
capitalist
to identify and scale up novel
technologies for covet diagnostics
speaking though of rising to the
challenge this year
let me introduce you now to my friend
and
a wonderful colleague who's been an
absolutely vital leader in this
effort dr anthony fauci director of
nih's national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
if it were not for the physical
distancing requirements
we are adhering to faithfully at nih in
the time of covid
this auditorium would be packed with
scientists rising to their feet
and cheering for tony's leadership in
science
and in public communication so welcome
tony
thank you francis for that very kind
introduction
i'm very pleased and honored to be here
with you today
to kick off this very important
situation that we're in right now
is to initiating the vaccination by the
moderna
product as i was sitting there listening
to francis i could not recall something
that happened a long time ago in this
very auditorium
where many of you are sitting right now
when i first came to the nih as a fellow
in training for my medical residency
in the summer of 1968 i was introduced
into the extraordinary place that we are
in right now
the national institutes of health where
so much of the research that has gone
into
conquering many of the diseases that we
know now
have really been addressed in such a way
as they've had a major impact
on the health of the nation this is true
of covert 19. it is particularly
meaningful
to me as a member of the nih for so many
years
to be receiving today with secretary
azar
and francis collins and several of our
health care providers
a vaccine that essentially had its
origination in the fundamental basic
research
that's conducted here at nih by our
scientists
as well as by our grantees and
contractors over the years
this what we're seeing now is the
culmination of
years of research which have led
to a phenomenon that has truly been
unprecedented
and that is to go from the realization
that we're dealing with a new pathogen
a virus that was described in january of
this year
to less than one year later to have
vaccines that are going into the arms of
so many people
including myself and so i consider it an
honor to be part of this process so
thank you very much
and now it gives me great pleasure to
introduce to you
the secretary of hhs alex azar
thank you everyone for joining us at the
nih today on this
proud and happy occasion i want to
express my deep gratitude to dr collins
dr
fauci so many members of the nih team
for their hard work
throughout this pandemic and especially
on various elements of operation warp
speed
i also want to recognize and thank the
staff of the nih clinical center in
particular
you have continual kickoff of the
vaccine developed by the nih vaccine
research center
madarina barta and other research
partners
and i'm pleased to be getting this
vaccine myself
we've all said it is nothing short of
miraculous
to have a safe and effective vaccine
within one year of a novel virus
becoming known to the world
but we need a medical miracle we know
where to look
we look to the brilliant dedicated
scientists at the nih
and we look to passionate relentless
researchers at america's innovative
biotech companies
as a member of the hhs family it fills
me with great pride that the nih and
other parts of hhs played such a
significant role in developing this
vaccine
which will save thousands and thousands
of lives and help bring this dark
chapter to an end
in the long and storied history of the
nih this is one of your finest
accomplishments i also want to recognize
the years of work and investment that
went into delivering this vaccine
it took more than just one remarkable
year but years
of dedication to develop the mrna
vaccine technology that many once
considered a long shot
once we have defeated this pandemic i
believe that both the success of
operation warp speed
and the mrna platform technology
pioneered by nih and barda should
reinvigorate our optimism about the
frontiers of medical science
and how we can bring the public and
private sectors together
to tackle our toughest challenges
when i look back on my time at hhs
putting together operation warp speed
will be one of my proudest memories
not only because ows vaccines will save
lives
but because they have reminded americans
to think big
when the government and industry charge
together toward a really bold goal
we can achieve unbelievable things i
know that these kinds of efforts have
been a focus for dr francis collins
the active partnership that he mentioned
which he has spearheaded under ows
involves more than 20 pharmaceutical
companies other government agencies and
other partners
and the nih has also continued to expand
its accelerating medicines partnership
for other serious health challenges like
alzheimer's and schizophrenia
to close i will note that as
extraordinary as this scientific
achievement is
getting this vaccine is more or less
just like any other vaccine we receive
we have to follow the right mass wearing
and social distancing precautions today
but otherwise this is just like nih
healthcare workers or hhs
employees getting their annual flu shot
americans should also know that this
vaccine
has been through the kind of searching
and independent
review that they expect for any drug or
vaccine
at the food and drug administration i
made it a personal priority to ensure
that we were not cutting any corners in
this development process
that the standards and data being used
were fully transparent
and that the final decisions made on
these vaccines
were made by the same career fda
scientists who would make the decisions
on any other vaccine i'm honored to be
receiving this vaccine today
and americans can be confident in this
vaccine
and each vaccine the fda authorizes for
covet 19.
these vaccines are going to save so many
lives and help bring this pandemic
to an end thank you all for having me
here today
and on behalf of a grateful country
thank you to everyone
at the nih for your work this year
i'd now like to introduce dr balen who
is the acting chief of the nih
occupational medical service
who will be administrating the vaccine
today to our participants and she is
assisted by
nurse practitioner judy chen
our first healthcare worker to be
vaccinated is ebenezer mienza
a respiratory therapist he has been here
for 23 years
evie while we set up love to have you
share with us
why you decided to be vaccinated today
so this will be one of two doses that
everyone will be receiving
there's going to be a 28-day interval
between doses
so this is part of the consenting
process
that everyone will go through
so eddie will you share with us why
you're getting vaccinated today
well since this faction is about saving
lives
my job as a respirator is pushing myself
and my teammates on this front square
of this endeavor therefore
i cannot be more happy about
thank you for being part of this
historic moment
good
okay
okay
okay
wonderful great the first nih
thank you thank you so much
so as ebenezer makes his way down the
stage our our next person who will be
vaccinated is carlene samaday
and she is a nurse in the clinical
center's procedures unit
she's been here for about 15 years
now each of the participants today did
get a fact sheet on the
vaccine ahead of time so they had a
chance to read um
what it's all about as well as um the
dosing that i described earlier about
having a second dose
in 28 days
at the conclusion of everyone getting
vaccinated they will be going to another
location to be observed for about 30
minutes
i want to make sure there are no adverse
reactions to anyone
so carlene could you tell us a little
bit about why you decided to be
vaccinated today
[Music]
great protecting yourself and your
patients and your healthcare workers
wonderful
yes
[Music]
very much
okay
[Music]
oh
all right
okay
next we have dr jeff strich who is a
critical care
medicine physician in the clinical
center he has a background in infectious
diseases
he's also a commissioned corps officer
so he'll be in his uniform today
uh 17 1984
so jeff can you tell us a little bit
about why you're deciding to be
vaccinated today
sure um really first of all i'm thankful
to be getting the vaccine today
it's really i think to help protect my
patients who i see every day who don't
have covet
to protect my colleagues who are there
on the front lines with us every single
day
and then to protect my family when i get
home and ultimately the goal is to break
the transmission cycle so we can get
over the pandemic
well said thanks for sharing
thank you good morning dr destruction
are you good thank you okay
um so you'll be getting the modern
vaccine under the
emergency use authorization okay
and we drew up some doses and i'm gonna
use that left arm right here yeah
she can hold it
so
[Music]
okay
just hold it one more second
thank you so much
our next healthcare worker is therese
kent
therese is a nurse practitioner in the
critical care medicine area
thanks for being here today therese tell
us a little bit about why you're
deciding to get vaccinated today
uh well thanks for having me i'm
incredibly grateful
to get this vaccine today um
as my colleagues have said you know we
protect our
patients and our fellow staff when we
protect ourselves
um and i truly hope this gives hope
to others who have suffered so much this
year
that hope is on the way vaccine is here
thank you tris okay
and we spoke a little bit earlier also
thank you ms kent for being here
and uh left arm yes thank you for
holding it
you've done this a couple times before
already here
okay
all right thank you so much and um like
we said the
phone number in case there are any
issues later
[Applause]
okay thank you next we have
dr neelam jiri who is a physician from
the national cancer institute
she also volunteers at the nih covid 19
symptomatic car line and she works out
in the elements to make sure we're all
safe
in addition to her regular job thank you
thank you
thank you can you tell us why you're
getting vaccinated today
thank you uh i'm honored to be the first
few in line to be vaccinated to
protect myself and everyone around me
and to be part of this campaign to end
the pandemic
thank you thank you thank you for being
here
and i'm sorry i didn't catch which one
you want left and right okay
just make sure we get the muscle thank
you
and you read the papers that you were
given
any questions or concerns
[Music]
okay if you were
given yeah
[Music]
that's okay we're just on camera
all right
okay thanks for everything you've done
for us dude
[Music]
our final healthcare worker today is
naomi richardson
and she is a nurse who's been working at
the clinical center for about a year
and she works with covid19 patients on
the special care studies unit
there
naomi tell us why you're being
vaccinated today well i work directly
with coal patients so
i felt have an opportunity why not
thank you for doing that thank you for
taking care of your patients
okay any questions concerns at this
point
all right you'll be putting other donor
backs here you've read the information
you know how to get in touch with us
afterwards
excellent
thanks for helping out you must have
done this a couple times before
right
thanks for holding that up
[Applause]
and a round of applause for all of our
healthcare workers
so our next participant is secretary
azar
okay so you join us today secretary
you shared some of your reasons for
being here today but can you tell us a
little bit in your own words of why
you're getting vaccinated
sure so as as secretary it's on my
authority
that these vaccines are authorized and i
want the american people to know that i
have
absolute and complete confidence in the
integrity
and the independence of the processes
used by the fda
to approve these vaccines that i have
complete confidence
in the safety and efficacy of these
vaccines and i am just
so grateful to nih and moderna and all
the participants in operation warp speed
for bringing us to this point where
now we can see the light at the end of
the tunnel from this dark period
so thank you thank you
thank you mr secretary any questions
or concerns all right
and just one second a little band-aid
just in case of breeds
thank you so much son
and thank you
[Applause]
that's your return card
next we have dr tony fauci
hi 12 24 40.
so many in our in our nation are saying
if dr fauci gets the vaccine i'm going
to get the vaccine so
tell us a little bit why it's important
well for me it's important for two
reasons
one is that i'm an attending physician
here
on the staff at the national institutes
of health clinical center
and so i do see patients but as
important and more important
is as a symbol to the rest of the
country that i feel extreme
confidence in the safety and the
efficacy of this vaccine and i want to
encourage
everyone who has the opportunity to get
vaccinated so that we could have a veil
of protection over this country
that would end this pandemic
thank you dr thank you for coming today
any last-minute questions concerns nope
trying to get a good intro muscular
injection here
thanks for helping out
and before you let go
thank you so much
next we have dr francis collins
all right
dr collins tell us about why you're
getting vaccinated today
well it's an incredible privilege to
serve as the director
of the national institutes of health
where so much of this work
has been happening over the course of
this tumultuous year
i get to talk a lot about these vaccines
and their promise for ending this
terrible global pandemic
but it's one thing to hear me talk about
it it's another
to have me roll up my sleeve and say i
believe that this
is the way we're going to get through
this this is something that the evidence
has shown
in rigorous scientific analysis to be
safe and effective so i'm
rolling up my sleeve and i'm saying dr
balin
bring it on all right well thank you so
much
thanks for coming and showing us the way
little pincher
are you done yet
i just got lucky that was no
problem people excellent
thank you very much sir and miss jan is
going to give you a couple papers for
the thing
[Applause]
yes
and let me just say a word of thank you
to colleen mcgowan who has served as our
m city for this historic occasion
and who is now getting herself in line
to be the next person uh to receive the
vaccine
so um
colleen is going to tell us in a minute
why she decided to get vaccinated now
that you've quizzed everybody else
i get to quiz you
um i'm a mother of two children so i
think it's important
as a mom to show other mothers this is
an important thing for us to do for our
children
i'm also hoping to chronicle this on
facebook for all my naysayer friends to
show them that it's safe and effective
right okay
thanks for coming hoping to show us the
way as well
okay any last-minute questions or
concerns okay
you're of course wearing the ideal shirt
i'm just gonna put a lot of band-aid on
there
well thank you everyone for joining us
today
this clinical center has been referred
to
for its 67-year history as the house of
hope
it's been home to countless medical
advances many in vaccine
research today represents yet another
profoundly significant historical moment
for us
it's deeply gratifying to have these
halls at nih
now take part in the light that's
starting to appear
at the end of a long dark tunnel called
cobit 19
a light made possible by the power of
nih science
and our many partners
so as a closing prayer of gratitude at
this season of giving
i don't think i can do better than the
words of david from psalm 103
bless the lord o my soul and forget not
all his benefits who forgives
all your iniquity who heals all your
diseases
who redeems your life from the pit who
crowns you with steadfast love and mercy
who satisfies you with good so that your
youth is renewed
like the eagles bless the lord o my soul
and the people all said amen
our event has concluded i want to wish
each and every one of you and
loved ones a most happy and yes a most
healthy
holiday season we are a jerk
you